parler de cristiano ronaldo le
footballeur portugais est devenu la
personnalité la plus suivie du monde sur
instagram ses prouesses de footballeurs
ses dents blanches et ses photos en sli
pour eu raison de la chanteuse selena
gomez puisque c'est officiel cristiano
ronaldo vient de lui piquer la place de
numéro un au classement des
personnalités les plus suivies sur
instagram avec plus de 145 millions
d'abonnés il devance ainsi d'une courte
tête selena mais aussi kim kardashian ou
encore beyoncé il faut attendre la
dixième place pour retrouver un autre
footballeur répondant aux noms de neymar
suivi par 105 millions de fans celui qui
pourrait être sacré ballon d'or d'ici la
fin de l'année et donc la personnalité
la plus suivie au monde
une nouvelle qui devrait faire plaisir à
la personne qu'il aime le plus lui même
sont à quai nous tous pleins ils sont à
qui nous a vraiment dit alors tu dois en
faire un petit jeu entre nous et chez
nous aussi il vient de dépasser dont 2
200 milles falloir la chanteuse selena
gomez tient sur instagram 4 plus de
followers
zinédine zidane ou en douane paceman à
votre avis zidane 20,7 millions et
griezmann 22,2 beaucoup attention qui a
le plus de followers sur twitter
gilles verdez ou joey starr ou gilles
verdez est ringard et suivirent il alors
mais vous êtes suivi dans la rue alors
attention et bien regarde yard
regardez
[Applaudissements]
ouais et chérie sur twitter qu'elle plus
de followers
clara morgane ou le pape françois par
morgan regarde sur twitter attention est
richesse c'est le pape
il en a un délai que je suis attention
qui a le plus de followers sur twitter
nagui ou bernard pivot à maryvonne à
niveau nagui allagui pivot que maginea
pivot regard des couloirs sur twitter de
loin il est très suivi
il m'aide à l'arôme aux attentions et
qu'il ya le plus d'abonnés sur instagram
matthieu delormeau
regardez bien sûr
[Musique]
[Rires]
ouais
je crois que la messe est dite mais qui
alors sera tout d'abord il est hyper
connue en fait c'est un [ __ ] laveur qui
c'est un pote at elle dit même pas le
plus connu des ratons loi et ses remèdes
offert suivi fait plein de photos